I believe you go through the 1- n system
then it's 1122 33 and if you pass the
hardest reincarnation 33 then you might
go to the fourth dimension you you you
pass through this three-dimensional
realm which we're in right now because
right now we're in a third density realm
after we actually reincarnate to the
point where we get Consciousness to the
point where we understand what we don't
understand now then we go to a higher
round but you're talking about like
maybe one out of every 10 million okay
so you believe that but you don't
believe that Jesus could risen from the
dead like you believe in the
Supernatural no I believe he could have
been reincarnated is that what you're
telling me he was reincarnated I don't
believe what evidence do you have for
reincarnation I hardly believe something
that bleeds and doesn't die